first and foremost Luke P comes to my
sure I feel like he is really bold goes
all-in well what is your relationship
with Luke P like now Jed Jed just is a
really stand-up guy and I mean
good-looking too has apps as well okay
you know in counted I also noticed I
noticed you said something about how he
had that southern charm but he seems
kind of open and I thought that's Hannah
she's got that southern charm but she's
modern yeah so is Jed the perfect fit
for you will see my southern values are
really important to me the I am very
open mic Big Mike just fun and so fun
but then also so compassionate and
really good listener
Tyler tall yawning hi gonna go far I had
to say but um smooth and chill it's just
like a chill dude but really fun you
have a good pilot Pete just a sweetheart
I like a dude with a real job yeah yeah
okay I'm gonna fly me everywhere how
much do you like pilot Pete would you
tell me if maybe you're a potential pick
for new bachelor is amongst these
frontrunners
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]